hey guys how's it going it's Justine
welcome back to my kitchen and today we
are making something very very exciting
and I'm going to try extremely hard to
make this perfect now if you guys are
new here most of the things that I bake
in my kitchen don't usually end up well
but today I am going to be baking a home
pod cake today's video is in celebration
of the launch of the home pod I've made
a few videos about it already I did
unboxing and a really cool demo of it
I'll put a link in the description if
you guys want to check those out so to
get in the mood I'm gonna start off with
a beautiful soundtrack by the one and
only hey Siri play some DMX I can do
lots of things try asking hey Siri spell
the word entrepreneur hey Siri what does
happenstance mean or hey Siri translate
this is delicious into Chinese I will
say about the whole pod that I
absolutely love is it can hear you from
pretty much anywhere that you are in the
room even when you have the volume at
max level anyway we're here to make a
cake so just I got it I got to get the
cakes
I've already baked them the first thing
that we need to do is we need to level
off these cakes I'm thinking that I can
probably get by using three of them hey
Siri what do you think of me I really
couldn't say okay alright better you
don't Hey okay that's not level I'm not
good at this we're getting down to the
nitty-gritty who says that Scott of HQ
cheerio that is so perfectly level I
cannot get more level than this actually
I probably could but it's good enough
you go replying the first layer here so
this is how we're gonna connect this all
together well link it's like a little
bit of glue
[Music]
play some party music this pitbull hey
Siri who is this
this is fireball featuring man I really
wish I wasn't gonna get a copyright
strike hey Siri
stop playing I'm having a little bit of
a problem because I'm afraid that this
is gonna fall over cuz it definitely is
starting to tilt so what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna jam these knives into this and
hopefully uh this will help stabilize it
so no to anybody that's like wow I
really want to take a big bite of this
cake you should probably be very very
careful hey Siri I think I think that
you're my best friend sorry I don't
understand understand dealer that's
holding up nicely so we finished one
container of icing already but anyone's
like just saying what to do this weekend
oh I just made a home pod cake hey Siri
what do you think about being a home pod
I think therefore I am
but let's not put the cart before the
horse
we are gonna be covering this in fondant
so this doesn't have to look perfect but
I do want it to sort of be as smooth as
possible cuz I am gonna be putting
another layer on it after we take it out
of the fridge this is gray fondant and I
am beyond impressed at the incredible
color match this almost looks exactly
like it so now I gotta roll this thing
out hey Siri play roll out Wow I'm
extremely impressed with my fondant
rolling skills this is probably the
thinnest fondant that I've ever rolled I
know guys get hikes so one of the key
things that I'm trying to replicate on
this home pod is it has this incredible
mesh covering so how do i duplicate that
here I got some of this burlap garland
20 feet 6 meters I don't know I was at
the craft store I'm like Jenna we gotta
find some burlap this is definitely not
sanitary so if you think I'm gonna do a
taste test after this I'm not okay so
this smells very bad Oh Mike this is
poison smell this you gotta smell it
just do a quick smell whoa Wow death
let's hope this works
so we're lay this here and do a little
roll
[Music]
we're gonna add a second layer of icing
to this before we apply this fondant put
this back in the fridge for a few more
minutes and then we're gonna cross our
fingers and hope that this all works out
guys we're having some issues I put too
much powdered sugar on here now and this
is sticking to I've absolutely no idea
if this is gonna work
but we're gonna try it oh this fondant
so thin I don't even know this is gonna
work
as long as one side is covered what we
can fix this we can fix this it's fine
everything's gonna be this is not
anything that I had pictured at all this
is absolutely disgusting I'm so upset if
anyone says Justine you didn't try hard
enough like I actually don't think that
I could have tried harder do you think
this is funny things right now now that
it's already falling over so I need to
prop this up a little more like jam this
fondant so from this angle it Ullman
looks acceptable and trim around this
bottom a little more I can't believe how
bad that looks behind like it looks so
terrible I think I'm gonna need to have
a professional make me a cake for my
home pie party that I plan on having
because this is not acceptable my
friends what expect this from me but
this is not the quality that I'm going
for
okay what size do we need the big one
okay there we go oh look at that oh
there's a hair on them oh that's
disgusting so something that I want to
do because this is very shiny I have
this clear piping gel it looks like this
it's gross
just give it a nice Sheen it is almost
identical so as you guys can see here
this is my home pod cake and this is the
home pod you can see some slight
similarities as far as the color and
that's about it
hey Siri do you know who I just seen is
Justine ezarik is an American YouTube
personality host actress and model five
million views across her YouTube
channels since 2006 oh wow and Wikipedia
would you like to hear more no but am I
gonna approach a billion views soon cuz
if that's the cake the answer to that oh
haha I wasn't talking to you I was just
talking yeah apparently I'm a host
actress and a model so that's some new
information thank you guys for watching
if you want to watch my unboxing of the
home pod or a demo of the home pod I've
got those videos below in the
description and I'm sorry my spirits
have you went from here to here like I
started from the top and now I'm at the
bottom Drake needs to write a song about
me
place started from the bottom now I'm
here
that's it I'm done I'm defeated it was a
nice attempt I'm so sad this looks so
stupid
[Music]
you